MERRY CHRISTMAS.
♪ ♪
I AM "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" ONE,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
STAY ONE THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT ANGLE.
BIDEN HITS BY THE FANS.
THEY HELPED PUT JOE AN OFFICE
AND LIBERALS EVERYWHERE FIND
THAT THEY TOO ARE NOT IMMUNE
FROM THE CONSEQUENCES OF HIS BAD
POLICIES.
NOW THE VARIETY SCENE LAYOFFS,
HITTING THE BIG TECH SECTOR
WHICH IS OVERWHELMINGLY PROVIDED
EMPLOYEES AT ALL THE BIGGIES
LIKE ALPHA, AND ALPHABET DONATED
MILLIONS TO DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGNS, AND OF COURSE IS WAS
ON TWITTER, THEY HELP
NONMONETARY WAYS AS WELL.
BUT NOW, THEY MAY BE WONDERING
WHAT THEY GOT FOR ALL THAT MONEY
BECAUSE THE REAL BILL IS COMING
IN THE FORM OF LOWER CORPORATE
EARNINGS.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY DIRECTED DUE
TO THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT
BIDEN'S POLICIES TRIGGERED.
AND NOW, I DIDN'T FRIEND AND BIG
MEDIA ARE GETTING WALLOPED AS
WELL.
NOW CNN, HAS ALREADY ASKED A
BUNCH OF REALLY TALENTED FOLKS
IN THIS WEEK IT WAS
"THE WASHINGTON POST," THE B
CELLS OWN PAPER BOASTED THE
MOTTO, DEMOCRACY DIES IN THE
DARKNESS DON'T YOU LOVE THAT?
BUT THEY MAY CONSIDER CHANGING
IT TO -- NEWSPAPER DIE IN THE
BIDEN ERA.
WHEN POST-PUBLISHER WETLY FOR
STAFF THIS WEEK TO ANNOUNCE THAT
MORE LAYOFFS WERE COMING IN THE
NEW YEAR, THINGS GOT VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE VERY QUICKLY.
WITH EMPLOYEES DEMANDING ANSWERS
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
NO WAY FOR THE END OF THE VIDEO
WERE GOING TO PLAY, THEY SHOULD
MEAN THIS -- WELL MAYBE THE FIRE
IN ONE MOVE.
>> DID GETTING ELIMINATED?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S JOB OR THEY CAN BE
TREATED LIKE A MAGAZINE STAFFERS
WERE?
>> WILL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
IS MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
[REPORTERS TALKING OVER EACH
OTHER]
>> YOU ARE DISRESPECTING THIS
ROOM.
>> A THIRD OF YOUR GONNA BE
FIRED A HAPPY NEW YEAR.
NOW IT'S EVEN UGLIER OVER AT THE
HOME OF OUR GLOBALIST FOX CATS
ON WALL STREET.
JUST YESTERDAY, GOLDMAN SACHS
ANNOUNCED MASSIVE PAYROLL CUTS
AS WELL.
UP TO 4,000 PEOPLE.
THEY'RE REPORTING THAT THESE
LAYOFF ARE ASSIGNED THE CUTS ARE
ACCELERATING THE CROSS
WALL STREET, AS DEALMAKING IS
DRYING OFF IN THE EXECUTIVE
BANKING REVENUES HAS PLUMMETED.
NOW, LET US NEVER FORGET THAT.
IT IS WALL STREET'S MONEY THAT
PUT JOE BIDEN IN OFFICE.
IT IS MEDIA COMPANIES ON THE
EAST AND WEST COAST, THAT TO
THIS DAY PROTECT BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION FROM SCRUTINY.
ALL THROUGH THIS YEAR, THEY
ACTIVELY HELP THE BIDEN TEAM
LIGHT TO THE VOTERS ABOUT THE
TRUE STATE OF OUR ECONOMY, AND
WHAT ARE BIDEN SPENDING AND TAX
AND OIL AND GAS WERE DUE TO
INFLATION.
SO THESE FALSE PROPHETS
PROMISED, THEY PROMISED THAT
INFLATION WOULD BE MILD, EVEN IN
THE SMARTEST DEMOCRATIC
ECONOMIST WARNED OTHERWISE.
THEY PROMISED A JOB MARKETS WERE
STRONG EVEN AS EURO WAGES WERE
FALLING.
THEY PROMISE THAT THE ECONOMY
WAS DOING GREAT EVEN AS
AMERICANS WERE LOSING TRILLIONS
IN WEALTH.
AND THEY PROMISED THEY UKRAINE
WAS WINNING DEFINITELY WINNING,
EVEN THOUGH ZELENSKYY IS
DEMANDING TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, PLUS PATRIOT MISSES.
THEY PROMISE CRIME WOULD SUBSIDE
WITH COMMUNITY POLICING, AND OF
COURSE IT IS WORSE THAN EVER.
AND YES, THEY SAID THE BORDER
WASN'T GOOD CONTROL, AND AS WE
ALL KNOW IT IS A DISASTER.
SO WHAT DID ALL BIDEN FANS THINK
WOULD HAPPEN?
FOR DECADES, CITIES LIKE
NEW YORK LOS ANGELES
SAN FRANCISCO, THEY THINK
SYMBOLS OF EXCELLENCE.
THERE WERE SOME OF THE SMARTEST
AND MOST NATIVE AMERICAN MINES
LIVED AND WORKED.
BUT NOW, THESE URBAN AREAS ARE
SYMBOLS OF AMERICANS DECLINE.
SO HOW MUCH LONGER WILL PEOPLE
TOLERATE THESE RESULTS?
A LOT OF BIG TECH A BIG LIT
MEDIA LIVE IN THE CITIES.
I WILL BIDEN'S BUSINESS AND
MEDIA ALLIES CONTINUED WITH THE
CHARADE UNTIL THEY'RE ALL BROKE?
SAYS DELETE NOT TO SUFFER, AS
THEY GET A TASTE OF THEIR OWN
MEDICINE, THEY WISH TO TRANSFER
THAT PAIN TO YOU.
THE BIG GREEN ANNEX ARE COMING
FOR THE STICKERS OF AMERICAN
LIFE, BUSILY PLANNING AWAY TO
TAKE BASIC CONVENIENCES AWAY
FROM THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
IT BEGAN WITH FOOD, THEN THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN THE
EFFORT TO BAN RED MEAT BECAME
POPULAR.
KAMALA HARRIS EVEN VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FROM THE PUSH.
IN THE ALTERNATIVE, WELL IT WAS
TRULY HORRIFYING.
>> TURNS OUT COWS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY OF MAKING BEEF.
YOU CAN PRINT ANY STRUCTURE THEY
ARE ABLE TO DESIGN -- SO YOU
UPLOAD A FILE TO THE PRINTER,
AND YOU CAN PRESENT A STAKE OF
PRETTY MUCH ANY SIZE, AND ALSO
DEPRESSION.
>> BUT IT TURNS PEOPLE HATE
THIS, FOR GAMETE CELLS ARE NOT
PLUNGING BECAUSE OF HIGH PRICES,
AND BEING TOO WOKE FOR
CONSUMERS.
AND ALSO TASTE TERRIBLE.
BUT THEY ONLY SEE ANOTHER BELT
EXPOSED.
YOUR CAR, THE LEFT WANTS TO MOVE
AMERICA FROM THIS -- STAY ONE
HEARS A COUPLE OF THINGS AMERICA
GOT RIGHT.
CARS, AND FREEDOM.
>> AT SIMPLE HONEST VALUE.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE KNOW WE
CAN DEPEND ON.
>> AND MOVE US ON TO THIS.
>> HERE WE ARE, THAT'S IT.
AND THERE'S NO SOUND OR FUMES,
THERE IS NOTHING.
BUT HOW DO I KNOW IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING?
>> IT IS.
>> TO THINK OF ELECTED BUSES
OF COAL, THIS ELECTRIC SHOCKS,
THERE'S ELECTIVE TIES,
EVERYTHING IS GOING ELECTRIC.
>> IT IS SO EMBARRASSING.
AND THEY SEE THIS BY THE WAY IS
A BATTLE THAT THEY CAN WIN.
AND REMARKABLE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" YESTERDAY
EXPLAINS HOW, IN THE FACE IS
QUITE SIMPLE.
CARS ARE BAD BECAUSE THEIR
EXISTENCE PROMOTES RECENT
TENDENCIES?
DURING THAT.
ENDED LEAD TO HAVING TO THAT
FREEDOM THING.
NO SOONER AS THEY COME THIS ALL
BEGINS.
AN AMERICAN CONSUMER LAWYER, THE
AUTOMOBILE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
FREEDOM MACHINE.
LIBERTY LIES ON THE OPEN ROAD.
DURING THE COLD WAR VEHICLES
ROLLED OFF THE ASSEMBLY LINE
WITH NATIVE AMERICAN NAMES LIKE
PONTIAC, APACHE, DAKOTA,
CHEROKEE, AND WINNEBAGO.
THE ULTIMATE EXPRESSION OF
CAPITALIST TRIUMPH.
AND MANIFEST DESTINY.
BUT FOR MANY, LOW-INCOME AND
MINORITY AMERICANS AUTOMOBILES
HAVE BEEN TURBO BOOSTED ENGINES
OF ANY QUALITY.
WHILE, THE LEFT REALLY HATES
CARS.
BIKE LANES EVERYWHERE, THERE'S
NO PARKING IN ANY CITY, HYPED
GAS PRICES, NO OWNERSHIP, JUST
RENT FOR AN HOUR OR TWO AND A
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT.
THIS IS THE GLOBALIST COLD.
AND THEN THE END IT'S ALL ABOUT
MAKING YOU LIVE WITH LESS AND
GETTING USED TO LIVING WITH
LESS.
A NEW GLOBAL ORDER OF MODELED
OUR POSTERITY.
TELL YOU IT'S BETTER FOR YOU,
YOUR LIFE AND YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH, A MEMBER HOW CLEAN THE
AIR WAS DURING THE PANDEMIC WHEN
EVAN MOBLEY STUCK AT HOME?
LIVING LESS IS GOOD FOR THE SOUL
THOUGH SAY.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
INNOVATION HAS MADE THE WORLD
BETTER AND HEALTHIER.